the godskin duo probably one of the
hardest boss fights in eldon ring and
maybe in the entire souls series at
least while i was doing this boss fight
because this fight has been giving so
many people trouble that an entire
reddit thread was made to complain about
how brutally unfair this boss fight is
listen to one of these comments godskin
duo has genuinely made me not like this
game anymore this is the worst double
boss fight fromsoft has ever made it
would be fine if it was just the two
bosses and that's it but they [ __ ]
revive and you have to kill them more
than one time each to beat the shitty
ass boss i doubt they will but this boss
would be so much better if they just
made it a normal duo boss fight and yeah
he's pretty much right this boss fight
is really hard i struggled with it for
hours and hours and i was complaining
that this fight may not even be possible
unless i was a sorcerer build pumping
out damage to both of these bosses at
the same time kind of like this clip i'm
about to show you guys
but you know i am a strength dex build
like i've always done in the souls games
and because of that this fight is
insanely hard but after hours of
attempting this boss and dying over and
over again i decided to try and level up
my strength a bit more and upgrade my
weapon to see if it would make a
significant difference and i kid you not
the only thing i did was level my weapon
up one time and i one shot the boss
first try returning to the fight which
is what you're seeing on screen right
now i still had to use my summon i still
had to use all my flasks i was still
getting pretty ganked by this fight in
general but essentially this fight is a
damage output fight you have to make
sure that you're doing enough damage
with whatever build you're using doesn't
have to be a strength deck spilled but
you need to make sure that you're doing
enough damage in general to have one of
these enemies dead during this fight
they share a health meter so doing
damage to either one can lead to you
beating this boss maybe this is just me
but i definitely prefer focusing on the
skinny one over the fat one the fat one
just has an insane moveset that i just
can't get down to dodge consistently
once i got the skinny one down i focused
on the fat one and i was doing enough
damage where i could just kill that one
pretty quickly as well then the skinny
one respawned again and i just fought
him normally until he snapped his
fingers as well to spawn in the fat one
while these enemies are snapping there's
a significant amount of time that they
give you to get some damage off before
the other one spawns in then it's just a
pretty normal fight until their health
bar is gone so basically this fight
completely stops your progress and seems
almost impossible if you're just not
ready to do it yet if you're just not a
strong enough level you don't have
enough strength in your build or
whatever scales with your current build
you have to make sure that you're strong
enough and upgraded your weapon enough
to do enough damage to keep one boss
essentially out of the fight the entire
time that is absolutely the key to this
boss fight so hopefully this video
helped leave like subscribe all that
good stuff and i'll see you in the next
one
i want this over with
throw your fire
thank you god it's finally over
oh
oh it feels so good